hey everybody its Jesse and I hope
everybody had a nice weekend I had a
long weekend it was a holiday here in
the US yesterday so that's why I didn't
stream yesterday and I tried I tried
really hard to take a break from coding
since I've been a little bit burnout at
the end of last week so I think I went
to full day's without coding anything I
did do some work on Saturday but Sunday
and Monday I did nothing so it's been a
really long time since I learned two
full days without coding anything so
that was that was kind of nice relaxing
so today we're going to try to get
Google Analytics working with this so
there's we have Google Analytics already
on there if you've been watching you
might remember when we added that in but
it's not working
exactly the way we wanted to I knew this
was going to happen I just didn't have
time to deal with it before the launch
and as I suspected we haven't really had
very much traffic so it's not a big deal
that the analytics aren't like a hundred
percent what we want them to be but I'd
like to get them up and running the
right way as soon as I can
so we can start getting the best data so
let me show you what the problem is well
Alex I'll tell you what it is and then
I'll show it to you in case you're not
sure what I'm talking about
we're using client-side routing so when
the page first loads Google Analytics
loads like normal
okay the tracks a page you but then
after that when we click to another page
in the site the analytics code doesn't
do anything it doesn't register that a
new that it changes has happened so no
data gets that so I'll show you
what's going on and let me pull this off
for a second and I'll bring in the site
okay so I'm going to I've got the the
real-time analytics up right now
and all this is showing is just who's on
the site right now and what page they're
on ok so right now I'm on the team page
I'm going to hit refresh let's see if
this will do it for us let's see if we
refresh will trigger if I'm gonna have
to completely open up a new there we go
okay so refresh triggered this then I'm
on the team page right now okay and
that's registering should be on the map
yep that's where I am so now when I go
let's say to the about page nothing is
nothing has happened it's not coming up
that it's about I can go over here
courses events none of these are
registering and so we are getting like
an accurate count of how many people are
coming to view the site but we're not
getting an accurate count of how many
pages on the site they're visiting all
right we only get that first page you
and then if they happen to do a refresh
a full page refresh to manually then we
get that all right but it would be nice
to know you know all the other pages
that they go to so that's what we want
to set up and normally I've set this up
for single page apps before where you
have client side riding without a page
refresh and it's not really huge do you
just modify the code but in this case we
have to be careful
we we don't want this to run on the
server side and we don't want to in
particular we don't want to look for let
me show you the code so you know talking
um what we're gonna do sorry I was just
kind of rush getting ready so I got it
I can't remember where my windows are
okay so what we need to do is look up
basically like the path name so it will
be something like instead of we're going
to get rid of this code actually and try
something different but you know we
would make basically make a page you
mean you know when we get the path name
so we would look at window dot location
dot path theme well on the server there
is no window objects right so I don't I
don't know for sure if that would create
an error and mess the site up or if it
just wouldn't log anything but I don't
want to take that risk
and and try to run this so I'm not my
first idea when earlier today was well
you know let's just you know through
this code you know edit this code a
little bit and we'll throw it in on you
know some point like component did mount
or something like that and we'll see
what happens but I thought no I don't
really want to to risk you know messing
anything up I I wish we would have had
time to test this out more beforehand we
don't so now at some point we're going
to have to put this on the live site to
see if we're really getting any reading
and Google Analytics at some point I
would like to set up maybe a parallel
site so that I could you know do some
testing on that but you just don't have
it right now so here's what I'm thinking
I went on to some using next Jas before
I go any further I'm just going to check
hey everybody I have some people in the
live chat that said hi so I don't want
to ignore him hey it was somebody from
the Philippines awesome okay all right
so we're using next Jas that's what so
we are using react but next Jas is
basically kind of like a way to scaffold
your react
app so it sets up a lot of stuff for you
like server-side rendering and routing
although we are doing some custom
routing it it does handle a lot of a lot
of those things that might be difficult
especially if you're first starting out
with react you know you don't really
need to know how all that stuff works to
be able to make something with reacts I
could really bog you down from from
being able to try it out so it's really
good if you used create react app before
it's they're comparable things they both
let you get started with react quickly
so normally in a react project we'd
probably be using something like react
router and then there are really
specific instructions for how to get
Google Analytics working with react
router but with next I haven't been able
to find specific instructions so what I
did find is an issue about adding the
script tag so I assumed other people had
the same issue and that was correct
assumption so a lot of people have also
been dealing with this and some of the
things like this this uses Google tag
manager well we're not using Google tag
manager so I'm not going to try that one
obviously um there's some other
solutions like down here it looks like
this is working when you use react - GA
or - GA so I decided to take a look at
that I looked at how he implemented it
here let me blow this up so far so you
guys can can see it a little bit better
uh this site that he's referring to the
he built but it's pretty awesome and
intricate but there's so much other
stuff going on that it's hard for me to
follow so it's not really a good example
for me to use you know because this is
this has a lot of other stuff built into
the way it's doing things is so
different so luckily recently within the
last couple of weeks
someone posted this so this is what
we're going to try I'm not entirely sure
exactly where all this stuff goes to be
honest with you but hey that's that's
how it is sometimes so this is going to
be a little bit of I'm not really sure
how this is going to work out but I want
to get this working before I leave today
and I'd like to leave early since I put
in so much extra time the last few weeks
so let's get started all right so I'm
going to move this out of the way for a
second so we can go over to the code and
I'm going to bring this over um let's
see
lost my lost my window again sorry let
me bring this I think I pulled it out so
I would have it ready and I lost it here
we go okay just to show you what we're
going to use this is it so it's it's a
package NPM package here that's
specifically for using google analytics
with react so we're not since we're
using it in a specific way with next I
don't really think a lot of this
documentation is going to be that
helpful for us I did skim a little bit
honest I didn't I didn't really read the
whole thing in a detailed way so we're
going to install this and then we're
going to apply try to apply it from that
example that I showed you a second ago
alright so let's pull over our command
line so we can install this I was really
trying to find a way to not have to
install another package because that
means I would have to install it on the
server as well so that would be you know
a few more seconds of downtime for the
site when I update this I'd rather not
have any downtime so until I get the
setup where I can
switch off between two versions of the
site and have no downtime every time we
do an update there's going to be is
usually somewhere between 30 and 45
seconds of downtime if somebody's
already on the site or has been on the
site some of that's already cached since
we're using that Service Worker so they
may not realize the downtime or it may
only be for a few seconds for them but I
still would rather not have any all
right so we're here in in our folder for
our local version of this site and we're
using yarn so we're not going to do an
NPM install we're going to use yarn if
you're not familiar with yarn I think I
don't know if I liked it or not in the
description but you can look up yarn it
does the same thing as NPM but I think
it's a little bit faster so I've been
using yarn yarn so we're going to do
yarn ad and we want react GA okay so
that's done that's good now we can move
this over and let me bring back and
bring back this just to say this you can
see it in case you're just you're just
tuning in and you missed it
I'll make this bigger well I was a lot
bigger
oh there so this is basically what we
want to do we're going to import this
this reactivated we just downloaded and
we want basically these two functions
okay so this we probably don't need to
keep this this is just a chrome solo
this will tell us it's working which is
good we want to initialize this with our
specific code so the each analytics
property has its own code so we're going
to put our own code in there and then
this is what we'll actually log
Paige you so remember I said we're going
to look up we want the pathname alright
so since it's not really a real page
refresh all right we need to look up
what the URL is manually and then we're
going to set that as the page you
instead of the default and then on
component did mount we're going to
initialize it and then log it so it's
pretty straightforward pretty simple if
you've worked with Google Analytics
before and done any type of single page
application with analytics like this is
not new stuff I just haven't done this
before with next so hopefully it all
works I also haven't worked with react
GA before so what I'm assuming happens
like I said I didn't read thoroughly
through everything what I assume happens
is that there's something going on here
that will make sure that this doesn't
mess anything up when it we try to
render on the server side so I I assume
that simply because a lot of the
discussion on that that thread on that
issue and github was about that about
this not running on the server so that's
why I'm maybe it's not a safe assumption
but we'll find out all right so I'm
going to move this over so we can go
over to our code what I do want to keep
so let's let's just go to we want to go
to one of these interior pages I guess I
guess it doesn't matter we go to any of
the pages but I'm just going to go to an
interior page here and see how this
works okay so I just pasted this in here
hopefully actually not worked with like
multiple exports here so this is what
I'm a little bit not I'm not clear on
and you guys are going to see my my
inexperience here with this come out so
if anybody is watching this and saying
like where what are you doing dude just
let me know let me know if I'm going
wrong here because I'm not super
confident what I'm doing and remember
this this show is not about me being an
expert at teaching people this is about
giving everyone a glimpse into what I do
as just one you know front-end developer
day-to-day and hopefully we both learn
from each other when we do it but I
can't guarantee that I'm always showing
the best way to do things it's just the
way that I'm using to get the job done I
did have some people talking a lot yet I
don't want to ignore it completely so
I'm just going to take a few seconds
just to check out what's going on here
especially since I asked if anybody knew
what was going on Oh awesome so
humberto actually a bear to let me know
should I pronounce the H at the front of
your name or should it be more like
Umberto like a silent H I can't I'm not
sure so let me know I want to pronounce
it correctly because I know I I know you
you watch frequently but anyway Humberto
said he's giving me a daily boost of
confidence said what I'm doing is
amazing on this site and to keep it up
so I appreciate that
that's stuff like that makes me want to
keep doing this if it
any point I think that this isn't really
helpful for anybody then I probably
won't do it but as long as somebody's
getting some benefit from this
i-i'll keep doing it and I suppose as
long as my boss is cool with it I'll
keep doing it okay so he also says he's
only used on that framework but it found
ways to incorporate things that I'm
doing so awesome and I went into
listening look so that's cool yeah
actually uh I've had I've had to work
with dotnet stuff just like just a
little bit like super minimal with.net
stuff and I'm I'm just like I know
enough to like edit little things on the
site but I really don't know exactly
what's going on when you talk that stuff
so that's that's really cool maybe when
I have to do some dotnet stuff then you
could you could help me out and I'll
definitely stream that Jimmy says please
monetize so I can watch an ad haha okay
when I help with this okay all right
till Umberto says it is a silent age so
I apologize for pronouncing the H before
I will remember that and it from now on
it will be unbearable and no age someone
asked if I know how to work with laravel
I do not know how to work with Laura
Bell the only guy know about Laura Bell
and hopefully this is right is that it's
it's a PHP framework correct I have
worked with PHP before but usually only
in the context of WordPress or making
like a little file uploader or something
for for a small site so that's that's my
extent of my PHP knowledge okay I'm
going to go back to this and see so
basically I just copy paste this into
here I suspect there's a way that this
can
just be somehow in its own component and
we can import this and not have to
include this on every page but at least
for the purposes of testing this a
little bit let's just put it here and
see if we can get maybe this console.log
to come up when we test it all right so
this is going to be here now we need the
component did melt which we're not we're
not calling that on this page yet so
let's pull that in and we're going to
put that inside this component here and
the other thing we need I'm at might as
well put this in now although it doesn't
really matter when we're testing locally
is I need that that code and like an
idiot I look down at the bottom when my
foot is and another component here it is
alright so I'm going to grab this code
hopefully this this works and we don't
have to spend a whole lot of time
troubleshooting it although it might be
a more interesting video if it doesn't
work all right so I'm going to save that
and we'll go over to our site here and
I'll bring up dev tools so I think I
already have it up somewhere let's see
here it is okay we're going to go over
to our console and we're going to
navigate to the about page and see if we
get a pitch it should say something here
in the console what are we looking for
ga and knit we did not get it let me
still and get it okay didn't get it so
it did not work right off the bat so we
also I mean we didn't get any crazy
errors either in Quetta kinetics
monstrance why are we getting this um
we are getting a 404 error which is
crazy haha all right so this is like I
don't know if anybody caught the really
dumb thing I just did but I tried to
check it on the live site instead of on
the test site so sorry about that little
ASA time let's bring over the test site
now so I'll have a lot of windows open
I'm sure I'm sure somebody else can
relate to having a million tabs open and
windows open so here is the site we
really want to test and I will open
analytics here I do want to check why
I'm still getting an error on on that
because I think I was good yeah I got
that error earlier and I fixed it so
maybe it's just some caching stuff okay
so we want to go to about I mean bring
up analytics we want to check the
console so again let's let's try this
all right we got it okay so we did get
this ga in it okay and that was
obviously a client-side route and there
one of the ways that we know that is
none of this stuff left the console
normally when you do a refresh unless
you have it set to persist your console
all this stuff will go away on a refresh
what is of it okay
all this stuff is coarse hairs going on
for images so for some reason it's set
on where these images are to not accept
requests
from localhost I guess so it doesn't
really matter for testing right now all
right so that's awesome so that's
working let's put it on a couple of
pages just to double-check and see that
it in fact is still working and we're
not messing anything out by including
this stuff in the head I mean I'd rather
have this separately but for now I want
to get this up and running quickly and
can always refactor and make it look
nicer later on and I know I always say
that and then sometimes I never get to
it but at least we'll try to get to it
all right so let's try the team page and
what else do I have open index okay
that'll be good three pages will be good
now what we also need to do is put those
functions and component did Malthus
function calls so where's my is my
original page so I know in index I
already have component amount so I'm
just going to copy the calls I I guess
it doesn't really matter the order right
now and I'm also calling it on the team
[ __ ] okay and if you didn't watch the
video on making jQuery work with react
that will explain why I have these calls
here to these functions this is to make
the jQuery stuff work that I was already
using on the site to make sure it works
when we do client-side routing I it
works already when you're doing a you
know full page refresh okay so you got
all those we have it on three pages so
about the index page was the home page
and then the team page so let's click
around and see what happens
so I scan go let's go to the home page
alright we got it
we have that in it console.log let's go
to the team page alright great we got in
it I don't know if you caught that but
we before I got all this stuff we did
get the anit I'm not gonna scroll but I
saw it happen so let's go back to the
about page okay and I'm just going to go
back up alright great so we know we can
we can go back and forth from pages this
is firing again it's working again we're
not getting any weird errors at least
related to that we're getting a lot of
other weird stuff going on with errors
you can you can check the live site
we're not getting all these errors in
the live site so that's why I'm not
worried about it alright so I think the
next step here is let's put this on all
the pages and let's push it to the live
server and we'll give it a test and I
have the link to the live site if if you
want to check out the site I also have a
link to the github repo if you want to
follow along in the description for this
video okay let me grab this part again
and luckily we don't have that many
pages so we can see one students who
have only have like five five pages
not bad for copy and paste let's throw
that end and here
and we're not actually using the single
news page right now if you remember we
didn't have content to fill this out so
we just left it out the whole the whole
news actually affect the news page and
single nerves are completely left out
but we ought to just put it in here
while we remember what you know how
we're doing this
you never know I'm like when that
finally does get added into the site
where we get the content I might forget
how I did this so I guess I could go
back and watch this video and now I just
want to pull I'm just going to pull
these think a lot of these pages are
more to use and component did mal okay
yep let me just close some of these so
we can see see what's going on
okay
you
all right and I think that's all the
pages so I'm going to push this to the
server I'm going to save it I'm going to
push it to github and then from github
we're going to pull it to the server so
if you've been watching you've probably
seen me do this several times already at
least so but if you haven't what then
you're not sure how to do this part
you're not familiar with git then I'll
just go through it again
so do get status it tells us everything
that's changed so all our pages
obviously but if you remember we added a
new package that react GA package so
that's why our yarn lock file which
keeps track of package versions and
things and that we never actually added
this directly and then our package JSON
file which we can edit directly but we
don't often those also change so those
are being included if you notice the
package itself is not included and we
don't upload our node modules to to get
up that's pretty standard you don't have
to upload them all because as long as
you have this package JSON anybody
yourself could you could load that on a
different machine or anybody could load
this and then just with that package
JSON file be able to install all the
dependencies so just a little a little
tip I mean I'm sure you could push your
node modules up if you wanted to but
that would it would just be out of a
waste of time all right so now we're
going to commit and I'm just going to do
one commit message for all of this since
it's all basically the same same thing
all right that that's not the most
descriptive thing in the world but
sometimes it's hard to come up with good
commit messages or function names when
I'm on the spot on YouTube so we're
going to get push
okay oh no what happened oh no this is
awesome that this happened though okay
because this is if this has never
happened to you before if you haven't
used it that much then you can you can
learn from from my mistake from me
alright so sorry I can see that there's
post to the live chat sorry for ignoring
this I will check it when we're done
with this I'll go through I'll read
everything so if you stick around if you
can stick around I'll answer any
questions that you put in there and if
you can't stick around you can watch the
recording and I'll answer it then so I
had edited on Saturday I worked from
home and I had made some changes to this
site I pushed it to get up and then I
pulled it into the server I forgot to
pull those changes back down to my local
copy here at work so what's going to
happen now is it has to to merge okay so
this is a pain when this happens and it
could have been avoided because I think
it's to maintain a good a good rule that
I tried to have and I always forget is
every day I should come in and start by
doing a get pool even if I can't
remember making changes I ought to just
do get pool because maybe I did make
changes and I didn't remember like like
today so and then you avoid that and
everything will be fresh so so now it's
time to pull these changes down actually
I can't believe it let me do maybe it
didn't haha it didn't I didn't even
notice it earlier sorry if I'm being a
weird here I'm just I'm laughing at
myself I try to make it get push um
earlier
and I didn't even realize that it got
rejected because I didn't pull yet so
earlier in this in the show when I I was
looking at the live site and I was like
why is that air there I fixed that well
it's because it hadn't actually I
actually went through the process
I thought of pushing it and then pulling
it into the server but I pulled in
nothing to the server there are no
changes because it never went up so
sorry if you're not familiar with git
and you have no idea what I'm talking
about sorry for being confusing but
let's do this properly now and let's do
a merge okay so we'll go through just to
let you know what this error message is
okay so the remote has stuff that I
don't have locally we don't want to you
know we want to sort out what should
actually be there in case there are
conflicting changes we want to go
through those and figure out what should
should actually be the change so we're
going to do a get pool and now it's
going to bring up I have set as my
default for this atom it might be
different for you maybe it'll be Nano
right in your text right in your editor
or if you're using some other code
editor
maybe you're awesome and use them who
knows so this this is you're just going
to type a message here to explain why
you're merging and I'm just going to say
merging
okay I mean that's pretty much exactly
why so now I'm just going to save this
and that should be X I can't do I need
to say maybe I need no all right so I
need to save and I need to close and
then it should it should go through
hopefully maybe not honestly I have
messed this up before so I'm not super
surprised
okay so let's alright let's try this
again
hmm okay so it looks like we have some
of the stuff here um let me do a log I
haven't done this command before so just
to explain git log will show us what
we've had what we've done okay yeah so
it didn't pick that up somebody saying
Patrick saying I have to close Adam no I
wish I I don't want to have to close
completely close out Adam here um how do
I get out of here thank you ski haha I
can't figure out how to get out of I
can't remember how to get out of log
there we go cute that's it okay so maybe
since I exit out of there let's let's
just see if it makes me do it again
local changes so the following files
would be overwritten by merge please
commit your changes our stash them
before you merge all right everybody
this is I'm just going to commit these
changes
I'm afraid it's going to overwrite what
we did but since it's not a big deal and
it's only those two pages I'm just going
to do this please do not use this as an
example of what to do use it as an
example of what not to do you can see
how much of a pain it is if you just
don't pull first so I'm usually the only
person working on projects so if you are
used to working on teams you're probably
looking at me like this guy's a noob I
just always forget to pull because it's
always usually me working on it and
usually from one computer so this is
something I don't even really need to do
that often oh let's just say so I don't
even remember exactly what I changed
before okay
your branch or dementia have diverged
they have three and one different
committees respectively you get pool
okay now it's going to ask me to do this
again okay um I don't even odds alright
that's a horrible message but it's it's
not descriptive at all but I just want
to get through this at this point and
let's say that and now I am going to
close up this this tab let's see if
that's enough to make it work yes it did
all right so Patrick a good call on that
the problem I had the first time was
that I didn't actually close out so if
you see like this tab open I should have
closed out this whole tab it's that I
just closed out this document and that
wasn't enough so that was the problem so
that that would have been the right
thing to do in case you were wondering
sorry if I confused you by by messing it
all up all right so now we should
be able to push actually before we push
let's check our files and make sure that
our stuff was still there we what did we
have changes from pages events and
resources so let's just look at one of
those events all right we still have
everything we need there and actually I
remember what I changed so let me look
in the events page I added a button with
a link here okay we have that button now
so everything that was changed is there
just wanted to be sure let's make sure
there we go all right so now that's
there let's go to the server so we're
going to have to do one extra step that
we haven't done before on the server so
I'm already logged in I just use SSH to
get into the server I'm gonna nope
nothing's coming up when I'm typing so
maybe I did get logged up and it's just
a little laggy I'm not not gonna realize
it I'm going to give it a second if not
I can always open up another tab and try
to get in that way
hmm there we go
it probably worked on this one not too
all right so I can close this up all
right so let's login using SSH and then
my user name and the IP address now we
you normally use this command so let me
bring this command over for you I'm
going to copy and paste it this is the
command we have been using and it's it's
just chained together basically what we
need right so we have a we're going to
stop our server we're using p.m. 2 to
manage that and then we're going to CD
we're going to you know go into the
react folder per project and then we're
going to pull from github and then what
we would normally do next is run the
bill but since we pulled in another
package we need to do something else
we need another step in between there so
I'm going to go back and we're going to
do an NPM install and and then we're
going to do the rest of it ok so we need
that step otherwise that code we just
added when we went to like here when we
went to sorry I didn't make this bigger
I apologize been doing this whole video
and it was probably too small for so you
see so we went in and we're called we're
trying to import this but it's not going
to find it unless we install that first
so it's going to read our package JSON
file and it's going to see hey at once
and once this react GA but we don't have
it yet so it's going to install then
it's going to go in with the rest of it
which is going to build the app again
and then it's going to restart the
server so let me hit enter and we can
watch it work I've been I don't know how
much time this MTM extol had hopefully
not that much time and we can still be
under a minute of of downtime
okay so you can see now it's installing
it's already done the pool there's the
change in the package.json okay so the
install went alright
mornings are okay as long as you don't
have an error the installs usually find
that we're building the build process
usually is like 30 seconds sometimes a
little more and as soon as this gets up
there we'll test it assuming that it
works then I'll check out the live chat
and I have another interview from syntax
con this time a short interview from
Emily Freeman that I'm going to show
here hopefully in a few minutes because
hopefully this works and if you haven't
seen the previous interviews that I did
some last week they're just kind of
giving some advice to people who are
just starting out in coding alright so
this is on line if it says it's on line
now let's test it out let me bring over
the live site actually I think I closed
that window that I had earlier so I'll
just bring it up right here catechetical
yes alright so it works I'm going to
bring up the console if you remember we
left that console login which at some
point we'll probably take that out but
we can see that part's working awesome
okay so let me move this here because I
want to see if this works so we came in
at the home page right and we have here
this last year this is the home page now
I wish there weren't five users on it
right now which it was just us that
would give us a better test but
basically we know that one of these is
probably us so let's click about and if
this works we'll see about show up here
I guess I can make sure on the console
we did get another console here yes and
about did show
so we have one about let's make sure it
just wasn't somebody else coming on
we'll click around we have a team we
already have one team so it should
switch to two here in a second
yep to four team nobody's on courses
right now so let's go to courses and see
if it works here that's you all right
awesome okay so there are courses so
there we go so it works we now have a
proper analytics coming in even when
we're just doing client-side routing and
there's no page refresh so just to wrap
up we're using next js' okay which we've
used to pull in you know react and build
that out we're using the client-side
routing there that comes built in with
with next Jas and we've pulled in the
package the NPM package react GA and
we've just included that on every page
just like this is super simple we've
included it we have some functions we're
initializing and then we're setting the
page view to what that current path name
is for that window and we're sending it
with this function we're sending it to
Google and then on component in mount we
initialize we run these functions the
init function and then with the sin so
it actually ended up working exactly
like like I thought it would work
exactly like we talked about the
beginning of the show and that's pretty
awesome the biggest challenge was doing
a git merge which is embarrassing for me
so all right Umberto's says that user in
washington is probably an oh cool
all right so oh we get we got a couple
people in washington it looks like
Bellevue Seattle all right so one of
these is umberto from from the live chat
they're so cool yeah if you're on now
you can see yourself your little dot
Google Analytics is a huge time
thing for me is it's cool to just check
out all these maps and see what's going
on everywhere so I try to stay away from
it when I can otherwise I waste so much
time in there
oh nice Pat Patrick is this like on
point today with with the great advice
Patrick says um the little what's that
called it's healed it the little Toyota
will terminate a frozen SSH session so
I'm going to try really hard to remember
that because that will be useful for me
thank you so let's let me go through
some of the stuff in the live chat
quickly and see if I can answer your
questions before I do the I go to the
interview and actually let me bring this
up so that I don't forget to do the
interview I'm just going to bring this
up right now because I did forget
previously you can actually kind of see
me in the background here in that
reflection so all right so let me go
through any tips on how to make a
nice-looking navbar um
I personally I like the material design
style and I think it's nice to be able
to work from a set of this like
established um kind of rules for design
guidelines so I would check out a
material design documentation on how
they do nav bars if you type in material
design it should be one of the first
things that comes up the official one if
you want to use a framework check out
materialized as a framework it uses
material design and it has nav bars I
like to try to start with that and then
change it as I need to fit the use case
I find that to be a lot easier than
trying to start from scratch it does
depend on the site I'm going if I was
going like a site for me like my own
portfolio or something which my own
portfolio site is super old I haven't
worked
like five years so if you go there be
kind but if I were doing some site that
I had like total artistic freedom with
let's say and I could do something crazy
maybe I would do something different but
normally like on a site for a client or
for the college where I work I would
probably start with something that's
kind of like tested proven like
something that users generally expect so
that they'll it'll provide them with a
familiar user experience they don't have
to learn how to use my navigation when
they go to the site so hopefully that
helped I know that wasn't like really
technical if you have some code or
something up on github send me a DM on
Twitter or in the comments below or
something below this video and I'll
check it out and I could give you maybe
some more detailed tips
all right Vladimir says it's a really
cool thing by streaming real work
awesome I'm glad I'm glad you like it
that was probably it's probably one of
the few original ideas that I've had
that you've seen is the idea to just
stream me doing my regular work I don't
I at least have never seen anybody out
stream the regular work so maybe I'm
just probably somebody else out there
that was doing it before me but at least
from my perspective I did come up with
that idea on my own update the live site
first I must have been it must have been
one of the times where I messed
something up and some of the other
comments had update the live so first
you're hitting a live set oh yeah haha
yeah it looks like everybody else caught
my mistake except for me and eventually
I caught it okay I
as who's saying sorry if I'm
mispronouncing your first name says can
you make a HS make a hoc and wrap the
pages in if you don't know HS e is this
higher-order component that's that's a
good idea
and i'ma tell you the only reason that I
didn't use high ORAC components here is
because I'm still learning about them
and I'm not super confident with doing
it yet so I've seen examples of other
sites and kind of look checked out there
the github repos and how they did it but
I feel like I keep using this as an
excuse but it's totally true because the
timeline was so short I really had to
stick with things that I like I knew
we're going to work I don't like to do
that I always do like to kind of push it
and do new things but that's just how
this worked out so the next project
hopefully will have a much more
reasonable timeline and I can try some
things out maybe like some of your
suggestions that you all are putting the
live chats and and really kind of make
it even better and just expand you know
what I'm capable of doing but yeah in
general from what I know and what I've
seen of higher-order components that's
that would have been a good way to go
for some of this stuff but I'm like I
just don't know enough to have used them
confidently okay at least I'm better to
saying he knows about the the conflicts
in the in the pool stuff so I'm glad
it's not just me I cry cronies I don't
know how you should say your name but
it's it looks like cronies with
Tuesday's at the end I says well a
one-man team I don't I'm not really sure
what you're referring to I don't
remember what I was doing at that point
of the video so if you're still watching
and you won't explain that I can I just
I just can't remember what was going on
there what that would be referring to
Kishor says hello hey how's it going
and okay Mossad said can you tell us
what you did so far because I joined
like five minutes ago so I did do a
little recap at the end if you came in
after that basically we're using we were
using client-side routing so our Google
Analytics wasn't picking up all those
those jumps between like pages of the
site so we just changed how we were
loading Google Analytics to be able to
pick up all those things so that's
really simplified version but if that
sounds like something you're interested
in check out the replay which will be
available about like just a few minutes
after this stream ends okay Patrick I
was wondering about Patrick says its
two-day period not just tilde okay so he
says there's there are other commands
that work with tilde so good to know I
wondered about that I saw the period at
the end and I wasn't sure if I was
included so if you want to terminate a
frozen SSH session Patrick has a good
advice here use t oday period and that
will terminate it
so all right let's say so Paul says cool
to watch this live work
I'm glad glad you're enjoying it it can
be a bit overwhelming on just how much
there is to learn for someone who is in
a few a few months in I totally
understand that yeah I am the only the
best advice I could have use I don't
worry about trying to learn everything
at once you know just take it like
whatever you need to know for a project
you're working on you know learn that
and eventually you'll get a better
understanding of of what you need you
don't need to know everything there's
just way too much out there to know it
all and you'll get a feel as you keep
doing it you'll get a feel for what you
like and what you're good at and that
will kind of steer you in the direction
of you know where you really want to
learn to I think to be really good at
something you have to rule out other
things at some point because it's just
too much to shy
be awesome at everything so the more
you're into the more you'll get a feel
for that but just you know don't don't
feel too overwhelmed I mean I don't
think everybody knows notice at all you
know we there there are people who are
just really good at they're in little
niche of what they do and they're
probably some people who just know a
little bit about a lot of things but
yeah don't don't worry about it I know
it's a lot to know but you know you'll
look back in a couple months and think
like man I I know so much more than I
did and and it'll be an awesome feeling
oh okay so we got an explanation about
says well a one-man team he said that
because I'm working alone okay
awesome sorry I didn't get that at first
yeah I guess there are perks to working
alone but then also they're not so like
there are a lot of sites right now that
like let's say I went on vacation and
something happened to the site there is
no one else here at this university that
could fix the site but me because
sometimes maybe it's just an access
thing or it would take somebody too long
to try to figure it out so there's
that's not a good thing
um but hopefully that's going to change
and I will have some other people
that'll that'll know what's going on
that's part of the reason why I think
these videos are so good that somebody
could look back on how I built this site
and probably get a pretty good idea of
what's going on you know from the github
repo and from these videos they could
piece together most of what they need to
know to work on the site so I'm it's
it's not really why I'm doing this like
completely but it's an extra bonus
included so that would be cool to work
on a team I think it'd be awesome to
have somebody else to learn from and to
be able to look at my code and that's
what I mean you all are kind of
fulfilling that role that functioned for
me you know you see what I'm doing and
you are giving me so much so many
[Music]
umberto just said in code comments nuts
nuts I
I was thinking it in my mind when I said
it like that's what comments are for
yeah I definitely need to to level up my
comment game in my code it's when you're
the only person maintaining your code
it's so easy to get lazy about comments
and style I'm hopefully I'm going to try
to get some of the computer science here
involved in developing sites so some of
them they may actually you know get paid
to work um you know work for me and some
of them might be interns at that point
I'm going to have to really set like
this is the style we use for CSS for
JavaScript and this is these are the
conventions we use and you got to
comment everything and I'm going to have
to get more disciplined at that point
I'm gonna have to probably slow down at
first but it probably it'll be better in
the long run and if I'm more disciplined
about that so so yeah thanks for calling
me out on that Umberto it's totally true
so that you're I need any better
comments all right I think I got it let
me read these last few comments I think
we're through okay awesome
chronic Ronnie's um says he's working on
his portfolio he's been working with
lamp stack in few j/s so yeah I'd be
happy to take a look at your site and
just let you know you know what I think
also that's also be working on the UJS I
hear a lot of good things about it I
haven't worked with it yet but at some
point I'll probably check it out if I
get a chance I just I kind of like I'm
torn like do I really want to learn
another framework or don't want to just
focus on react and try to get good work
good with it but at some point I would
still like to check out you okay awesome
so I'm pretty sure I got through
everything if you have a question and
you didn't get to answer it put in the
comments below
if you don't want everybody in the world
to be able to see it on YouTube then
just send me a DM
Twitter my link to my Twitter is in in
the description also now that I launched
this site I'm going to have a little bit
extra time I'm going to start making
short tutorial videos and putting it on
my youtube channel so if you want to be
alerted when those videos come out you
can subscribe um I don't really care if
you subscribe or not but I'll probably
let you know too on on this channel when
those videos come out so alright so I'm
going to play this video that I've had
up on the screen for a while and this is
Emily Freeman and I filmed this at
sentox con two weeks ago when I was
there and she's going to give some
advice to two new coders oops
and I forgot I need to put the sound on
it so hold on a second alright okay so
you should be able to hear this now
alright so wait what's I'm in like I
ripped in for Colorado um here it's a
text not giving it song what see doctor
actually exam it won't on hope you
dumped a me a story of DevOps gone wrong
and then the doctor says can taxation
and then what else you know from you
doesn't uh to what we do with your yeah
yeah I am a job in Melbourne I builds
ApS services I have figured out a way to
make that more in just a minute but yeah
in Java for a small company and what's a
new technology that you're excited about
I don't know if it's like a new
technology but I am excited to like just
learn another language so I'm gonna jump
from last year starting and remains my
favorite but then I'm super interested
in either picking up like a gun or an
elixir something like a little different
cool and what advice do you have for new
programs just keep going I think it's
really easy to get discouraged
don't feel like you're the new person
and never going to get it but you will
be amazed at how much you are overtime
and so it's very hard to kind of see
your growth when you're in it and so
that means finding a mentor or trust
appear and to kind of remind you how
awesome your arms just keep going you
got it thank you yeah all right so oh
cool thanks Paul says great interview
yeah hopefully that the interview was
helpful I have one more interview from
syntax Khan to do and I'll probably do
that tomorrow
so it was great talking with you all
there's a lot of good stuff in the in
the live chat I'll be back tomorrow same
time 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time and like I
said let me know let me know if you had
any other questions I think I already
cover that right I don't repeat myself
you know where to put the the questions
okay actually I do want to mention this
to this good advice Cronus says
meetup.com is a great place for people
to meet other developers so I haven't
been there but I guess check it out and
okay you're welcome guys Humberto is
saying thanks so anyway I'll see you
tomorrow I'm gonna try to head home and
enjoy the nice weather that I'm having
here so thanks for watching see you
tomorrow